julien et étienne propriétaire d'une
boulangerie et pâtisserie française à
sao paulo ont trouvé un moyen pour
pallier la baisse d'activité en pleine
période de pâques
il mise tout sur les commandes par
téléphone ou sur internet situation et
fait que les gens ne sortent pas de chez
eux
donc on n'est pas on apprend n'attend
pas client on va les chercher chez eux
aussi
donc on a communiqué via les réseaux
sociaux
en juillet ces actifs sera pas comme
horizon qu'ont livré les chocolats de
pâques à la maison directement julien et
etienne ont ouvert leur boulangerie il
ya un an grâce aux livraisons leur
chiffre d'affaires n'a pas diminué
depuis le début de l'épidémie pour
accueillir au mieux ceux qui préfèrent
venir chercher leurs baguettes malgré
tout ils se sont adaptés gel
hydroalcoolique tables installées à
l'entrée de la boulangerie protection en
plastique pour restreindre au maximum le
contact entre clients et employés
tout est fait pour minimiser le risque
c'est important le matin d'avoir ses
petites habitudes de venir acheter sont
ses viennoiseries sont peints de
continuer à vivre un peu sortir de la
maison plus avec avec cette pandémie on
est on est enfermé en quarantaine ça
fait du bien de retrouver des gens qui
travaillent qui sont là pour nous mais
eux aussi expatriés en toile laurens
professeur de mathématiques à
l'université de são paulo ne peut plus
enseigner
il travaille désormais depuis chez lui
sur ses projets de recherche et donne
ses cours sur une plateforme en ligne
seul moyen de respecter le confinement
sans bousculer le calendrier
universitaire mais aussi de rester actif
autour de bonjour à tous tout le monde
est là aujourd'hui on va poursuivre
notre cours sur l'intégration numérique
il faut
il faut respecter des horaires stricts
donc ça ça permet de garder une certaine
discipline de vie quoi ça demande
beaucoup de travail supplémentaire mais
on a la possibilité de continuer ses
cours et de pas ne pas pénaliser cette
cette génération d'étudiants tous les
français expatriés au brésil n'ont pas
la chance de continuer de travailler
comme nicolas propriétaire d'un salon de
coiffure à sao paulo
depuis le début du confinement il a dû
suspendre son activité comme tous les
salons de la ville alors pour occuper
ses journées et renflouer quelque peu la
caisse il s'est lancé dans la
fabrication de masques avec l'aide de sa
belle-mère et à épouser des procès nous
quand j'ai posté une annonce sur un
groupe d'amis tout le monde a semblé
être intéressé par les masques du coup
mon gendre et moi avons commencé à en
fabriquer afin d'augmenter notre revenu
familial
cela fait plusieurs semaines que le
brésil fait face à une pénurie de
masques depuis que nicolas a lancé son
entreprise familiale
le téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner une
reconversion au poil pour ce coiffeur
français